Thirsty?
Would you like coffee, tea, or pee?
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
I've seen it in movies and heard it a bunch
of times, perhaps even from doctors: urine
is sterile.
Right?
Riiiiiight?
WRONG....actually.
Researchers at Loyola University have presented
yet another study about bacteria in your pee.
But first, let's back up a bit.
Urine is composed of 95% water.
The remaining 5% contain over 3,000 compounds
-- most of which are your kidneys disposing
of waste.
This includes extra nitrogen from the liver
in the form of urea, and excess electrolytes
like calcium, sodium, and potassium.
Electrolytes serve an important function in
the body: they help conduct electrical impulses
between your cells.
The impulses need to stay in check because
they control your hydration, blood acidity,
and muscle function.
Buuuut when you have too many electrolytes,
they can do ya dirty.
Too much sodium causes dehydration, and too
much potassium can cause a heart attack.
Urine also contains trace amount of acidic
toxins from your kidneys ANNND...bacteria.
Research recently presented at the American
Society for Microbiology found that healthy
bladders also have certain bacteria in them
that are excreted through your pee.
The researchers at Loyola also found that
people with bladder problems have a *different*
type of bacteria in there.
They say the idea that urine is "sterile"
simply isn't true - and those bacteria are
important!
What does this mean for those of you hellbent
on drinking your own pee?
Obviously you CAN drink your pee.
Nobody is going to physically stop you.
And we've all seen 127 Hours right?
If you haven't, you should, that was a good
movie.
But we've all heard these crazy stories of
people surviving off their own pee.
The thing is...the likelihood that they survived
BECAUSE of the pee is debatable.
When you drink your urine, you put back into
your body all the waste that it was trying
to dispel, thereby forcing your body to reprocess
it.
With each successive cycle of pee there is
more and more waste, and continuing to drink
it will quickly take a toll on your body as
the toxins build up and your body becomes
more --not less-- dehydrated.
This is especially true if a muscle is torn
because it can leak potassium and phosphorus
into the bloodstream.
Still, that doesn't stop some hardcore believers
in the practice of drinking your own urine
-- the real guy behind 127 Hours himself believes
it helped save his life.
There are also people who do it because they
believe it's healing.
"Urine therapy" is an ancient practice where
people drink their own urine to cure diseases
and cancer.
They also use it to moisturize their face
and fight wrinkles.
It's a practice that has been around for thousands
of years.
Urologists and the American Cancer Society
say that there's no data behind it.
In other words, if you have cancer, you should
probably see a doctor instead of drinking
a nice warm glass of your own pee.
Thanks for joining me for DNews: would you
drink your own pee if your were desperate?
Or for healing?
Tell me down below and we'll see you again
soon with more DNews updates.